the craziest news as of today is that
Donald Trump has announced the crisis
might last until August
yeah that's nuts August I don't think
that's gonna be the case though I don't
know man and I don't think so I don't
want to speculate it's hard to say he's
saying like July maybe August and of
course all the media outlets are like
the end is nigh in the markets on fire
and it's like the worst drop in history
but we we are trapped in the house
because it's 8 p.m. and we're not
allowed to go out as the governor of New
Jersey said that this is really funny
what he did so because he actually
caught me with this and I got I got
tricked he said that they're instituting
a curfew and residents are strongly or
the residents should stay in their homes
from oh no what do they say residents
are not to leave their homes from 8 p.m.
to 5 a.m. we are strongly recommending
or something like that like it was
really cleverly worded that what ended
up happening was some news outlets
picked up the story as though it was a
mandatory curfew right because it was
warded in such a way where it sounds
like the government wants to say but
they can't legally say so you know so I
called the local police and I and
everybody I called them yeah I did and I
said you know I'm hearing now the
governor saying that we're you know
we're locked down
movie theaters gyms stores everything's
closed by 8 p.m. yeah all restaurants
are only takeout and the cop said we
have been advised of nothing oh wow so
as far as I can tell there's no like
functioning curfew I mean it is kind of
smart to just stay home like why would
you want to go to a bar anyway right now
dude people are dumb
have you seen the videos there's like
this this blonde chick and they're
interviewing her while she's like
drinking and like leaning on her friends
and she's like I'm like
immunocompromised but I take supplements
oh it's totally fine and like there's
like thousands of people in the street
like I'm in a thousand but I couple
hundred on the sidewalk why because
people are dumb man you know or maybe
not I mean here's the thing you know
like we're all strapping young chaps so
if we ended up getting sick it's not a
big deal it's if the old people end up
getting sick yeah so here's the crazy
thing because the New York Times did
like this calculator and it's been
reported in the past
week that 40 to 70% of people get
infected and if there's a 1% death rate
we're looking at like 800,000 - like 1.5
million and if it's the high end this is
the New York Times showing this is that
if it's the high end 3% and a 70% 70%
infection rate seven million in the
country dead that's a lot of people a
lot of old people yeah so that's that's
why you know they're they're forcing
everybody stay in it's kind of funny
that when it comes to well they're not
forcing they're strongly suggesting yeah
he said the governor said I am strongly
discouraging non-essential travel after
8:00 p.m. or whatever yeah but in the
official like reporting from various
local outlets it said that it said local
residents are to remit remain in their
homes from 8 p.m. to 5 p.m. in a
shocking in a drastic and shocking new
effort recommended by the government
that's what they said so it's like you
finally get to the end and it sounds
like they're it's mandatory and then
they're recommending it I was like wait
how are they instituting a
recommendation that's that's like weasel
words they're trying to trick people in
a thing they can't leave but they can't
legally enforce it
well I'm sure it's working though Oh
totally I'm sure no but most people are
not going out but I'm where are they
gonna go anyway you know but I'm willing
to bet it's setting the opposite effect
as well as that I already know some
people who have ditched out there like
I'm gone down meaning left the state
yeah okay yeah yeah like beus yeah
because as soon as they start saying you
can't leave is when people are like we
better leave now
and everyone everyone's got a different
flight time right for me I'm like I
wouldn't I wouldn't bug out right now
because they're strongly suggesting an 8
p.m. curfew but if they instituted like
a 24-hour non-essential lockdown the
first thing I would do is I'd get in the
van and be like peace because the border
to the state is 10 minutes yeah the
bridge is right there yeah that's right
now you load if they close that bridge
what are you gonna do other bridge where
does that although bridges yeah that's
true yep it might close all the bridges
that's the first thing to do because you
know what we're gonna we're gonna know
that public we're gonna close the
bridges then you drag we're gonna inform
the public and you drive 40 minute 40
miles up to the land where the you know
when there's a peninsula yeah yeah cuz
South Jersey's like a big peninsula but
it's it's you know like sigh right now
if they say you can't go out after 8
p.m. you know my first reaction was I
don't want to
dance in the streets no no no I don't
eat dirty but I don't want to go out no
I know exactly it's like we're gonna be
down I don't want to go either
let me talking about news and stuff but
if they start saying that you can't
leave period right then I'm gonna back I
can do my show from anywhere and the
last thing that I want to do is if it's
a bunch of dumb people who have no idea
what's going on and can't don't how to
survive I don't want them showing up to
my place and you know starting you know
asking demanding stuff taking stuff like
if you if you really get to that point
I'm not I'm not entirely convinced away
to that point for sure because if we
ever got to the point of like a really
hard like martial law type thing which
is not where we're at you'd have like
National Guard deployed yeah so I don't
I just don't see it I think for the most
part most people aren't flying aren't
traveling aren't doing anything anyway
but what the governor said was that
there are too many videos circulating
from Jersey of people like partying and
dancing at bars and it said there was
one video from a Jersey bar where I
think in Hoboken where they're like
handing around a drink and they're all
sharing it and he was like no we're
gonna issue all of these strong
recommendations now because it's like
you know North Jersey is New York Metro
so they're decently hit by this yeah
dude New York is gonna be a nightmare
it's gonna get bad yeah New York I mean
it's crazy what one even one person so
there's this graph that I that I saw in
or is it South Korea so the first 30
cases they knew about and were actually
handling it really well and the third
number 31 didn't like didn't listen and
said all right whatever I'm just gonna
go about my business went to church went
to business meetings went to all these
things and they like followed it through
all the different and then it like
that's where the infection spread and
then it went out of spun out of control
yeah thousand patient 31 was violation
31 yeah exactly yeah how how stupid man
these people so so for me I'm like the
governor ended his message by saying
listen we're all gonna do this together
this is about all of us runs together
and I was like I like that yeah okay you
know we do need a sense of community in
this country and a lot of people are
always every man for themselves but it's
a good point here that if you tell me
listen you know we don't want to we're
not trying to do this to you we're
trying to do this with you like if we
all agree to limit our exposure and stop
going out
yeah then it's gonna be done real quick
I'm like I got you buddy right I agree
100%
it's what's this concerning to me is
yeah you know I don't tell ya you must
stay in your house
yeah if right and so I think that was a
mistake if he just said I'm calling on
you to help and please you know stay in
something like that but I don't know man
Trump Trump has a released his
guidelines here we have them 15 days to
slow the spread this is this is straight
from Donald Trump retweeted it out
listen to and follow the directions of
your state and local authorities if you
feel sick stay home do not go to work
contact your medical provider if your
children are sick keep them at home do
not send them to school contact your
medical provider if someone in your
household has tested positive for the
corona virus keep the entire household
at home do not go to work do not go to
school contact your medical provider if
you're an older person stay home and
away from other people if you are a
person with a serious underlying health
condition that can put you at an
increased risk for example a condition
that impairs your lung or heart function
or weakens your immune systems stay home
and away from other people so there you
go that's the official official word
from the president and you know seems
simple enough yeah but I think this is
oh man I pulled the photos right now
yeah do I have them where don't they
have the photos right now now we'll pull
up and let the lungs yeah I got to
figure out where that do I even have it
I don't think I do
wait no I don't think I have the photos
there's crazy photos I thought I had
them but oh here we go there you go
there it is yeah yeah for some reason it
wasn't the right spot yeah this is why
it's scary because well where's the two
photos oh this is a and B there yeah
yeah so here's here's a and B and then
no this is just a where's the photo that
you had before click on that one which
one this one oh there isn't no there's
nothing there was a comparison there it
is further down here this right here
these two I don't know there was a
better picture the first one was like
you can clearly see the lungs and then
the second one the lungs were see this
is just a you can't see this again well
we found this video or this this picture
and I mean you can see the lungs here
the second picture is double the amount
of white
and I mean I'm not a professional so I
don't I can't really say no I honestly
have no idea what any means like so here
let's read it says pictured the first CT
image taken of the male patient who is
otherwise in good health the slightly
discolored region to the left is called
ground glass opacities where air spaces
in the lungs become filled with a
substance usually possible out or water
growths
this one says the same patients that
have lungs five days after his initial
scans it shows severe progression of
pneumonia with increased of extension of
ground glass opacities and consolidation
thickening or swelling of soft tissue
yeah man
California is locking down the markets
tanking I don't know what do you what
are we supposed to do just sit around
yeah I mean you got a I mean social
distancing is is the key I guess you
know you got a stay away as much as
possible and you know this the whole
August thing makes me feel like they're
planning on on or expecting it to just
go through the whole population let's
see what they said it's if it's if it's
like I mean China's I under I think that
they're like coming to an end or not an
end but like a slowdown yeah yeah but
what is it three for three months now so
it's like like end of December till now
so they're starting to figure it out and
like we have been working on vaccine now
they're testing it now so we're at the
beginning of of the spike so if we kind
of push it out and the vaccine works you
know and then we can we can start like
actually you know saving people there
was what there so that they tried a
human illness there was a human trial
already so a woman right I guess there's
a woman she's like trial number one yeah
it started today and and yeah well and
we'll see what happens the court from
Trump he said people are talking about
July August something like that they
could be right in that period of time
where it washes through so if if you
consider that we got a kind of a leg up
on this although we don't wreck to the
best of our abilities I think in the
United States but we knew about what
China was going through I think June I'm
hoping because I'll say man if they're
you know there's this hump
we can't go to the movies well can't go
bowling we gotta think about the stupid
people out there that aren't can't that
don't care that thing there
they're above it and like I'm not gonna
get sick or even if I do whatever I'm
young it doesn't matter yeah but you're
infecting everyone else you're gonna go
home your parents are gonna get it you
know it's like that's that's what no I'm
just not accounting for the stupidity
and I think they are and that's why
they're saying are gonna be boring man
so they're NBCUniversal said that
they're gonna be releasing some major
theatrical releases like the Invisible
Man in the hunt on Fridays just online
so you can just read you ratchet yeah
you can just rent it to 20 bucks and
rent it 20 bucks
yep that's what this I pray listen man
this I gotta I wouldn't want to watch a
movie for 20 bucks this cry if I want to
no but you're getting the theatrical
release that's why they're doing it it's
a it's a rental like you're going to
watch the movie for watching at home
dude I think our economy's gonna be
dramatically transformed by this because
you've already got a bunch of people
calling for permanent changes and that
pisses me off yeah that's true
exploiting people's fear and panic to
implement massive government change yeah
completely undemocratic yeah I agree
dude it's pretty messed up so the next
the next really big story San Francisco
Bay area counties issue shelter in place
order officials in six San Francisco Bay
area counties issued a shelter-in-place
mandate on Monday affecting nearly seven
million people including the city of San
Francisco itself the good news is there
will be a much less poop on the sidewalk
thank you for that a shelter-in-place
mandate what is that I don't know that's
what you want to read it is in six San
Francisco Bay area counties issued
sweeping shelter in place mandate Monday
affecting nearly 7 million people
ordering residents to stay at home or go
outside only for food medicine and
outings that are absolutely essential
okay so they can go out but yeah well
same thing here yeah yeah all right so
the order says residents must stay
inside and venture out only for
necessities for three weeks starting
Tuesday in a desperate attempt by
officials to curb the spread of the
novel coronavirus quote I know too
order is a radical step it has to be we
need to act now all of us to protect the
public health says dr. grant Colfax
director of the San Francisco Department
of Public Health I mean that's true we
have to be proactive dude not go out Los
Angeles San Francisco Sacramento they
have massive homeless populations that's
that's what we're talking about
quarantining them yeah how do you
quarantine that they're gonna get sick
they just recommended they're like if
you're homeless you just need to try to
find shelter which is great that's a
great advice good luck
I'm sure a strategy is it as if almost
people literally just walk aimlessly
non-stop forever no they typically go
yeah they find somewhere they go
underneath something so what else is
going on we can't sit back and wait for
the federal government to do anything
yes thank you you can't know it it bugs
me out that people are like we wasn't
doing this debt and this like dude what
what is what these people and assuming
the government's gonna take care of them
for everything yeah the government was
was created to basically handle the mail
no I'm serious yeah and like the states
did everything and slowly and slowly the
federal government got more and more
powerful but and now everyone's like
well they're gonna fix it it's like no
they're not yeah why don't you pay
they're like Trump said it today the
states are doing a good job of handling
their own state things and now people
are like oh like giving him you know
crap for he said he's good he's every
man for himself but you know yeah and
it's like no he's saying the states are
handling their own states and that's how
it should be you know and and it's good
like you know Jersey is is basically
seeing all the stupid Jersey kids and
they're like you know what we got to
close the bars down so these stupid
Jersey kids don't kill all of our old
York to them and and New York I'm sure
you know cuz Jersey Hoboken that whole
area it's all you know it's basically
the New York suburbs you know so New
York is gonna be a disaster
yeah I'm surprised that we're not seeing
a lot more nightmarish news coming out
of New York now I'll give it a week so
yeah we were over 4,000 infected now in
the country okay according to this New
York New York Times graph I think this
this calculator thing was an excellent
way to explain because it's really
difficult to constantly tell people why
this is worse than the flu yeah because
people don't understand the rate of
transmission right it's not it's more
than the flu
and the mortality rate is substantially
higher yeah and so well everyone will
get it if you come in contact with it
yeah and so here's what's crazy is the
New York Times calculator shows you that
at the low estimates predicted it will
be the number one cause of death this
year it'll outpace heart disease by a
couple hundred thousand several hundred
thousand deaths that was the highest
that was a low estimate
yeah and heart disease is the number one
cause and so if you go to the highest
omotenashi to me they're still people
who think this is a grand conspiracy
just to take out trump yeah when I see
anyone like talk about wishing it on
anybody
well no no there are people who are
saying like real crazy coincidence that
just before the election with a record
economy this virus panic starts and it's
not even as bad as the flu blablabla and
it's like you you think Italy killed
thousands of people that's what I heard
from like over this is the beginning and
you think starting to Donald Donald
Trump giving press conferences and
announcing like yeah measures to protect
people is he's part of it like Donald
Trump is part of the scheme to hurt
himself look I get it maybe they think
that Trump is just desperately trying to
protect himself so he's playing along or
something but I think it's absurd to
think that all of these countries lock
down their borders a bunch of their
government officials like in Iran died
Italy is you know blocking on the entire
country major corporations are losing
billions of dollars the market is
crashing all because they don't like
Trump yeah do you know a man let's go
it's because disasters happen thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all in
the next show
you